Jesus the Beast jumped on your face
today didn't I just put on some [ __ ]
freshener dude now I need some bronze or
something bro dude you look like a
[ __ ] gay look again you look like a
homo you look like how easy no easy
homosexual construction that's what you
do who comes up trees just a [ __ ] child
molester always sells Dodge Neon you can
fill in the gap there with a PT Cruiser
epic si bro do you look like 21 Jump
Street you look how you got [ __ ] up on
21st Avenue dude you look like Lenny
from of mice and Massimo you goddamn
will not retire from hot Tom did you
locate the 50 year old vegan bro get
your life together man you came back
from Nashville and you changed man I did
yeah you change bro it might just be the
reflection off this hot strap right here
just not be old strap the one in the
only I don't want to thank everybody
that came out of Nashville because um
dude a lot of people came out a lot of
fans a lot of people just friends came
out of the show you came out of the
closet at the show bro damn was like I'm
day yeah I never just erupted with
jameth dude I've had somebody like spit
out a drink you know I've had a lady get
a couple like baby pains you know and
people like laugh so hard to get racist
yeah one guy was like [ __ ] Chinese
yeah like a man goes I didn't mean that
I didn't mean that at all it's just
unlost yeah so some dudes just like how
I did
Mankiller chillin with his buddies he
was cool we had his wife with him and
then by like ten minutes into the show
he starts sweating orders another beer
house starts mouth dry dry dry mouth
writes things that's what happens first
no see I feel like it's not the
salivating the drive first but gets wet
oh that makes I know how it works
yeah moisture starts in the back and
works its way up through your body
coming mountains and then and then next
thing you know the guy was like
explosion his buddies like have another
beer Daniel children go sit in your
truck to be fine walk it off walk it off
goes to some [ __ ] hang willies walk
it on but it was uh it was fun man and
Nash it was fun busy dude now that
you've changed dude I haven't changed
actually this is the first time I ever
worn by on the kid the LSU yeah I didn't
know you knew [ __ ] about football
really you're a football fan oh yeah man
LSU I'm LSU God dude they got I didn't
see that shirt before the season only
have a nine shirts B he wore this one
the first time was everyone firing the
kid when you guys at the first studio
that's like a year no probably three or
four years ago how long is all show
binning is a accent's five years six
years Wow
you're LSU fan now though especially
then boys are hot yeah I mean I think
it's I think it's what that coach oh
yeah I'm like Nick Nolte yeah oh yeah
it's frustrating to watch all the video
of him talking LSU head football coach
and if you're pale that got [ __ ] at an
into you that guy is tan he is you think
it's tan or you think it's just kind of
bad blood work like I feel like I feel
like I just filled with [ __ ] black
blood he could be a little bitter bin'
dude yeah he might be or you know what
maybe India might be full patchy I think
Oh homoerotic construction used to fill
when he was named LSU interim head coach
after Les Miles
and we called a like it hurts to talk
happy to have you here it's taking about
listen if we ittle bit about everyone
but I feel like we had the greatest
player Lenin for me oh yeah dude
in the season he's always you can't
close his eyes either dude
yeah boy I guess at 22 and 29 record as
head coach that ain't fun will your
throat gets real dry if you can't blink
your mouth is always open
oh yeah but I think even if these wins
already and a lot of that some of the
SEC - some of the SEC is pretty weak but
oh yeah Eidos iran reminds me of um you
know he's kind of uh you could tell he
probably has you know he's got a couple
of mix children and you don't even know
what mix you know he looks like one of
them dad's that lets his kids wrestled
alligators and [ __ ] really yeah he
definitely is [ __ ] on the side of the
interstate with a lot of percent you
know I'm all eating [ __ ] jambalaya
like a hot jambalaya in the middle of
food yeah I don't like a fart her to me
dude like a foreigner farter oh no oh
that face I oldest farts ambra that man
has [ __ ] respect for himself
that's not a forehead he has a hole that
is like a awning that is like a [ __ ]
it's just one strip that is siding bro
that's just a severe yeah it's like in
front of some old Buick it's just one
big boy on your ankles you I was riding
yesterday I ran too far in my shoes
[ __ ] up the night before I can stop
get a map no bro
I couldn't stop do you got to know when
it kind of real it seemed like you seem
like a guy that doesn't really know how
to like kind of real their own life and
like I've never ran too far yeah yeah do
you run oh I ran two miles yesterday
yeah and some why do I even get ready to
I mean whywhy go through the house of
working out yeah that's like I went to
the gym and I walked over the wall and
got my car you know I'm saying like why
get all your [ __ ] together in life to go
two miles
dude it's a hardy two out there bro
uphill also a lot of uphill
he's still eating just keratin [ __ ] or
what are you doing I'm back man I had a
little bit I meet I had ice cream last
night man
what was the celebration because you're
killing it on the road decided to
celebrate a little bit
yeah just made it through the weekend
dude I had me a couple fresh peaches a
buddy of mine may owe me three peaches
and uh that's weird dude no it was your
boss why'd your boys mail you fruit he's
a peach man he always I like an actual
peach oh yeah
he's got all three boy I like peaches
beautiful cherries - you said [ __ ] my
boy get in on my free standard roll on
dude for your life together
dude keep your life together dude I
don't have any friends send me peaches
and [ __ ] yeah well you got a lot of
issues man I have issues yeah you ever
seen yourself yeah you might be right
100% bro dude you know you slowly turn
into [ __ ] I mean you're here like
that first is a mullet they just have
full-blown chicken oh this is Swayze
dude yeah it's lazy bro so many people
stop and ask about the hair and
whatever's with the hair I could be
pushing like a senior citizen in a
wheelchair no bike-o who's this [ __ ]
yeah yeah anybody I'm like what are you
even asking for like I saw the hair and
then just respected this old person you
know like the hair is a lot of it I can
you think joy cause like I think of like
lesbian stepmom a little bit like a
little bit of a southern lesbian stepmom
did you have to get you Toby well I
don't know what you hate on that I think
dope like I feel like if they're doing a
sitcom on ABC and you walked in on a
dress they're like this your new stepmom
and people like oh that's cool doodie
you look right necro drugs you get a job
doing construction in West Hollywood for
the rest of your life rocker bro look at
you do you look like I do that eats
burgers and just carries around a
[ __ ] shotgun look whole have you seen
some of you guys are probably listening
on radio you can't see this man
on ham radio - grace grace quarter
woodchuck somebody look at that Jun you
I know bro look at your hair
[ __ ] me you look like you were that
Orange Julius and [ __ ] I would never
touch the kid and I have worked at a
smoothie place and I would never do
anything wild to a kid and I've babysat
overnight three times
dude I would not let you babysit my kid
well that's fine actually I was oh I
wouldn't want any tales son because I'll
be you know oh did you feel me okay like
in chopsticks boy these [ __ ] karate
makers right here bruh like a chimp
[ __ ] perked up when he saw these
puppies stone-cold killers at the airs
so no you need to get back on that old
New Orleans sauce you know back on that
deck Adeeb all know what we used to do
dude now they had a buddy of mine this
got Billy conforto and he was a
homosexual and we were Busboys he was a
bus man he looked like don flamenco from
Mike Tyson's punch-out remember that
show yeah with that man
yeah the rose yeah yeah yeah the guy who
was like a waiter during the day yeah
Google that [ __ ] chin [ __ ] man we're out
here describing this turn in American
bro he used to be so on it dude never
liked it yeah I got it out no the guy
that held on flamenco if you split Don
and there yeah Russian guy
Lena Russian bro wasn't a friend he's
French
my buddy looked just like him exactly
like you my buddy was socks Nick nobody
did he preferred [ __ ] but he was also a
boxer
dude he would fight he would bro he
could I mean he would fight you in and
[ __ ] you after if you wanted to he's up
to you guys but he was the toughest you
don't know and he was a busboy at this
place because they wouldn't let him be a
waiter because the guy who worked there
someone was had some issues he didn't
want gay waiter yeah that list though
this is distracting
dude no he was a fighter he was he's
probably the toughest you don't know
which was crazy because you know this
was a time you know when they didn't
have as many tough game in you know now
you got all kind of tough game in you
know you got um you better watch him
Peter WWE
yeah dude oh yeah I'm sure you got some
NFL dudes oh you got any apples
oh yeah you know some Browns oh yeah you
got some guys for uh but this was when
and Billy uh and Billy conforto and he
died he had a bunch of pills and drove
into an embankment but was that on
purpose or he's like trying to party I
don't know but I will say this man
whenever we were kids he we used to do
steroids on the side of the interstate
we pull off the side of the interstate
and just shoot each other nice to do it
because there's nowhere else in the
world to do it well do but nobody's
thinking oh those two guys along side of
the interstate there's think oh the car
is broken oh that's exactly what I think
really I think those two are injecting
d-ball in their ass and suck your crap
you don't think about that you should
think I would think about a million
other things before I would think about
I see you with that who do looks like a
French [ __ ] I would assume you guys
are injecting sucking winstrol and
sucking each other's great you look like
you work at a gay construction look like
you sell two-by-four skins you boy would
just inject each other and then be like
everybody else is like I'm getting a
sex-change alike now I'm just gonna
[ __ ] power I'm gonna I'm gonna earn
it
fortunately I'm gonna get it medically
bro brought your dick Cena hiding your
body and you're gonna be sitting down to
pee for the rest of your life soon if
you don't start taking care of yourself
I do I'm trying man so we pull off and
we'd spend time like that we would do
drug we would do uppers you know
muscular uppers and then we would hit
the we would hit the you know the gym
and everything and we all he also sold
weed so I used to drive them across to
New Orleans and he'd pick up like eight
pounds that we dude and I'm awesome dude
and the others demons though huh yeah
yeah he had his demons man he I think he
was like abused or something he was
growing up and he used to fight dogs too
he would fight pit bulls and Rottweilers
Wow what was his issue with them he was
just I think this is a time when you
know people like we're still like you
know probably treated gay people
strangely or something and so he didn't
know that Rob never from a Rottweiler
though but he so he's like I'm gonna do
whatever I can to be tough and dude he
people would and he would knock him out
brah he was a toughest he's a badass
who's bad ass bro he's a busboy so we're
out there slinging butters and [ __ ]
huff and whipped cream in the free
hey I'm getting loose getting loose what
do you mean working hard brave it a
busboy
Janet second really a topic at a grocery
store Janna do you seem like the
toughest [ __ ] at a Claire's boutique do
you still destroy a [ __ ] busboy you
inject each other in a silo highway then
[ __ ] each other we're just supposed to
breathe like it's normal
just go dude in the south on the side of
a New Orleans highway sucking each other
off
Oh gir that it took you look I get an
eight-year-old boy got an infection from
an ogre and there and this thing is
anything you look like Macho Man Randy
Savage he had AIDS man Randy tragic you
know like the war if we just know he'd
sure did it what dude watch your tone
you look like him if he were in the
second day man your baton Swiss dude
dude you look like Lenny from of mice
and mossy modes don't touch me dude and
it's the third time it's happening here
dude five times dude I'm calling the
police I will hold you and shave your
head dude look I grew up in the molester
Belt five times he touched me I'm
calling the cops
five I'm sorry about if I'll give you a
couple of buckets I'm saying you have
women's band-aids on the back here for
you these are major band-aids for
blisters yeah are you ready for them
he's broken dick
Rob never suck dick there was one time a
guy we were doing some cocaine in the
restroom thank God I had to go to the
airport and that's all that happened man
and that was in you not like you have
you ever
like in a threesome with your buddy in
your buddies now whoops yeah never been
in that so you automatically immediately
are way closer to bro and if I am gay
I'm happy dude if I'm gay one day I'll
[ __ ] somebody do it I'll [ __ ] your
stepdad you have a stepdad I don't
well then I'll [ __ ] know call your
real dad they didn't see how he's doing
I wouldn't be mad because with that
haircut like I get it but if you had he
looks kind of like a let's be honest
I've here to give your father was a gay
male would he date me you think and he
broke up from your mom if you shave that
goatee yeah if you clean shave if you
clean shave more like a tank top Maya
dinner and fear and more than two miles
and [ __ ] you [ __ ] you yeah you catch me
not doing that new that's how to get
back at somebody take care of yourself
and then date their daughter years down
the road you don't know the way to get
back on is like getting crazy shape and
get all like sexy and thick dudes what
do you girls like what onion thick
buddies like a mixed girl on Instagram
what are you talking about bro you too
skinny dude a lot of trying to lure my
dad and you better gain some weight bro
you too light in the ass a lot of people
like lean males don't thank chin what
are they like Ethel she likes she likes
lean black males you really ya know but
that's what people are saying now really
yeah white people saying you mean you
dude look I don't know problem with it
yeah come out the closet you want a TV
show come out the closet man [ __ ] a
brother you got to do something you got
to change the game up call it Chinna
SHhhh yeah just kill and [ __ ] skinny
black dude yeah chin adelphia
yeah that's you and it's a yeah you're
dating a new kind of svelte looking
urban guy he's Silence of the Chin's
yeah well bro he's a serial killer
dude I'll tell you this so I got real
high one time and they were playing I'd
never played this game charades have you
played it I've never played it so and so
have you ever played it yeah but have
you done electronically we're doing on
the on the thing you hold to your head
no ma'am I'll hold on
oh it's due on 18 no I haven't got out
the [ __ ] board with my family i'm
thanksgiving blade charettes go ahead
bro well I'd never played it dude him
it's a game where someone acts something
out and you guess what's going on yeah
and so I was so high and I sit down and
I start to end and I see what people are
guessing and the guy who was doing the
things was in a wheelchair you know and
he was a handicap that's tough and uh
it's not that tough I don't think you
know I think if you got the [ __ ] in you
know some people now are even on
Gurney's who aren't worried they used to
be in wheelchairs people yeah I don't
want them on my team though you know I'm
saying oh I don't either the other day
I'm at the Pizza Hut and his family
pushed somebody in her at hamburger
Hamlet and a family pushed somebody in
on the [ __ ] gurney that could have
been in a wheelchair goddamn that's lazy
bro
yeah oh I know that Pizza Hut huh
hamburger Hamlet no why did you go to
pizza I love pizza
dude on over Domino's huh the crust bro
when I die dude embalming [ __ ] yourself
put cheese in me bro dude do you wanna
be you wanna be stuff Christ bro imagine
you're laying there in the coffin dude
first of all I want raccoon hands no me
too no we're talking like no no yeah
dude bro calm down man this I'm not
Brian you'll have to just gave me out of
the [ __ ] room every day Oh Brian is
is you guys just trying to like argue
that you're not gay until one of you
guys just ends up inside and it's really
a hate crime even real gay dudes are
just like just [ __ ] each other guys you
don't say in the show is the most
flirting I've ever seen it's five years
ago five years so what had happened then
was were we talking about
well what bothers me is you're a Pizza
Hut guy oh yeah
pizzas over Domino's you're [ __ ]
crazy pizza was the only place to go
when I was a kid yeah me too but then I
grew up and realized there's other ones
you know like you ever had you ever had
Papa Murphy's
mmm-hmm where it that's no that sounds
like a guy it's actually on trial for
the Catholic Church right now I know
Papa Murphy's that [ __ ] cuz you've
heard of Papa John's right
yeah papa murphy's I don't know if they
have them la Ben Denver it's a [ __ ]
chain you buy frozen pizza you get your
pizza and I don't wanna get at home dude
so what really took place
I want to angry ginger manager yeah one
a couple of I want a black guy who
doesn't give a [ __ ] cooking my pizza
you don't want pizza okay oh no somehow
I don't really
yeah once that's time you uh chain
you're staying at Pizza Domino's will
bring two pizzas King at our sting it
yeah bro what pizza or Domino's yeah
dude dominoes dominoes is like somebody
took a can full of pizza flavoring and
sprayed it in a box and brought it to
your how it's my [ __ ] pizza he taught
his real pizza and his pizza and the
title he thought Saddam it was a [ __ ]
board game yeah selling you feet uh-huh
that's like hey how obvious is that what
should we call it well we we're in a
heart we make pizza yeah stupid at least
have pizza in the title I don't need
that to know they make a delicious
problem Domino's it's delicious oh my
god bro most people are dying
skateboards is that haircut come with
have you seen his [ __ ] haircut
unbelievable yeah both my seven and
five-year-old nephew dude let me ask you
with that lesbian haircut do you get a
discount on Subaru Outback how's that
word now are they just enforced green or
how's that work
dude this haircuts phenomenal I think so
I'm not mad at it bro yeah [ __ ] this
guy's at worst bro oh you're gonna die
soon you have a gym like i don't have a
gym like it's just a big deal dude you
should really be worried about it
what's weird about don't touch me again
you got three times already
dude I thought you fall bro no you're
[ __ ] bro dude come on man be cool bro
be cool man we'll be cool let me finish
my story yeah please do what was it
again Chen do you remember Pizza Hut
you're bombing
oh no well then I wanted crazy bread but
when you die I just can't believe that
those are the options burning first of
all cooking somebody that's get out of
here bro how's that even an option
that's terrifying
I mean it's definitely
they're [ __ ] you on that one how
about this they burn you and then go
we're gonna put your ashes over the San
Francisco bridge yeah [ __ ] and a lot of
dudes are down there on party bar just
catching a mouse yeah smoking myself
didn't shoot you'll be careful
underneath that going gate bridge
getting that shawl shower down there the
ashes yeah damn yeah Haight Ashbury in
your face grab him bro yeah but that
cried him back in you know so here's
what happened to me was uh so the pizza
hut oh I've told this story the first
time we almost met an Asian guy that
almost met an Asian was in we heard
there was a rumor there was an Asian in
town like you know near nearby 17 miles
away okay so me and two of my buddies
cut grass you know did y'all was on [ __ ]
no we didn't do tiki torches dude this
back when if you were racist she just
didn't tell anybody you just were at the
house you know well so this is a but we
were excited you know we say money me
and to my buddies cut grass to go see
this a rumored Asian okay cuz we'd never
seen one sure it's exciting oh the only
thing we'd ever seen was American Ninja
Warrior and even that doesn't do it
justice and it's not and it's [ __ ] up
if you think about it's just Van Damme
beating up Asian people never really is
talked true and they're smaller on
camera you don't realize how big there
are they really yeah look at chin yeah
butt chin is uh he's like Godzilla of
Korean oh definitely dude he play in
Godzilla he would play one of the
buildings yes you know or he play like
uh like the human giant that [ __ ]
so what happened was we got there we
took a taxi me and two of my buddies to
go see this you know rumored Asian and
we get there and was a pizza it burned
down right and you know pizza other's
unique roofs yeah like a hunt yeah yeah
cuz they don't you - hi-ya sells pizza
not Domino's oh yeah Domino's yeah I'll
order something from there that's not in
the title Oh where'd you get this
Chinese food Hasbro yeah yeah Hasbro oh
is this uh Milton Bradley [ __ ] sorry
everything has to have the [ __ ] no
but it's like at least it makes sense of
what it is okay so he's so obvious well
Little Caesars I assume I'm not gonna
[ __ ] Greek statue too
oh dude I'm assuming who's gonna be a
hungry boy coming over to [ __ ] player
you know what I'm saying
nope I love it so different for you so
if that delivery boy gets me to it a
couple times that's all new
that'll hold up in court too dude if you
lie named him little seasoned oh if I'm
half an eight ball deep in order Little
Caesars bruh and he comes with that
crazy bread too oh there better be a
small bowl with a mouthful of Olives
ready to frickin touch my [ __ ] yeah
but anyway so this this pizza had burned
down and there was a but that unique
roof they had was sitting flush on the
ground and people thought Asian people
lived in it that makes sense it doesn't
make sense now but at the time I was
like I can see how you guys could you
could see how yeah go to the go bring up
a pizza chin yeah just so people get an
idea the visual because they break they
have distinct roofs original pizza roof
this new thing now it's just a sign it's
a picture of the roof there is the red
roof bro yeah that's a hot that damn
thing was beautiful yeah I like them and
dude you go in there and they had those
glasses that were like thick and red
they're cool I can't open your heart all
the time it smelled like a [ __ ] pizza
parlor party plastic dad ice brothers
that game yeah yeah yeah I remember that
yeah look on one of them chin so I can
see it just one of the real ones that's
not that's not one yeah there we go
oh that's a new way what was that Isis
green one uh that's right
yeah yeah that's that [ __ ] right there
yeah I can't eat so that makes me happy
see
well well because it reminds in my
childhood that [ __ ] hunt was sick you
don't see those anymore man no and how
about Domino's went [ __ ] all y'all we
only do small little places to have them
deliver yeah no not strip malls they
just deliver bro
Oh Domino's is two years away from just
being a skill crane that you put two
dollars into and pull apart with one of
those little metal how dare you they
make such a delicious pie Domino's dude
yeah extra sauce on Donald's here's a
key there you are Itza and you yeah
extra sauce cuz they have two fresh
bacon that the fresh make it really yeah
because if you order the regular that's
right go that one's cheese just put all
these toppings on it you order extra
sauce they have to remake that [ __ ]
fresh
now some facts all have tongue rash is
anything hit Tom dude 30 minutes yeah
that doesn't mean fresh that means fast
it fast and fresh no you can't decide
bro yeah I'm used to a quality product
do we pull up at Pizza dude
one of us would be bleeding because we
fought all the way there in the [ __ ]
car my dad would get out my dad was 77
years old my mom would said yell [ __ ]
you that's how we went into every
restaurant just like that roll in there
my dad had the money dude he said he had
the money than we got there and he's
Loki bar the money for me and my brother
to [ __ ] pay for the food yeah so then
my mom would be in there sometimes she'd
be so pissed she'd sit at a different
table
cuz she didn't want to act like she was
with us and then we get a couple
quarters from my dad that he would
borrow from us first in the bathroom
fifty are two then we go back to the
tables bro hit the arcades we come back
and both my parents would be sitting as
far away from each other as they could
drink and dude and then it's gone yeah
then a dis manager a ginger I mean it's
gingers you could get I mean just again
you know you could see their organs all
of his organs yeah I pulled his shirt up
you could see at all you see all the
veins ecology one under his shirt was by
oak what you know bio one or what is
that class you guys take biology Jim
what is it biology yeah biology yeah so
right under his sure to his bio one you
know and they'd have it and then he
bring over some trainee every time it
was a young black girl she was a trainee
oh and she had like God this was back in
the day with a lot of you know a lot of
black ladies with suck on pacifiers at
work I was weird I remember them M&S
yeah and so this lady would come in and
they'd be like you know this is you know
and they had this girl nerteaux named
Asma Wilson they'd be like this is Asma
and she's a trained in and she bike I'm
about [ __ ] y'all you know [ __ ] your
pepper and [ __ ] y'all man would be like
three [ __ ] this dudes but walk Whitey's
you know and water water but then anyway
he would say she's a trainee and blah
blah blah and then they would messed up
the order and then they'd go
get the order right and then we'd all
sit there and have that power man and
that's back when it came in a hot pan
that a hot pan yeah it was like a cork
kind of thing they set it on and that
pan was about three inches stick of
[ __ ] yeah Oh bro they don't do that
any much what I'm saying it's change I'm
wit see original pizza on I [ __ ] with
okay when it comes to delivery its
Domino's all day but we can agree on
something we might disagree on that
Little Caesars can suck this dick well
little five dollar pizza get the [ __ ]
out of my face yeah and you're disabled
well look at their advertisement it's a
disabled boy in a diaper Kenny bring it
it's a kid who's missing a bit of
chromosomes and then yeah look at look
at that bro look at the nose on them
that ain't cool making fun those people
yeah it's not illegal but it's
definitely something that they're trying
to you know not have those inoculations
for baby so it doesn't happen anymore
dude here's the problem too they cut
their slices in squares really squares
they don't do [ __ ] triangles like
Americans yeah
squares bro I don't [ __ ] with it yeah
oh wow that huh yep think about it dude
ice to work at BJ's pizza dude and they
said it's tough for Black Jacks but it
low-key stood for [ __ ] pizza oh wow
and it was uh dude it was crazy and at
night we would take the trash forget to
fold up because everything in there was
straight garbage
I'm sure the dumpster out back we got
like a mini dumpster this was at a time
in our town where they tried to save
money by giving people know they're
thinking we can have less pollution if
we give people many dumpsters they won't
make as much garbage right yeah that
makes sense that's the worst idea ever
so then there was just a select carpet
but half of was laying all around these
mini dumpsters so our thing was we had
to get out there at night at the end of
the shift and burn everything in the
dumpster goddamn so we have to get out
there Dave put gasoline in that paint
stain you enough propane is a 495 and
hmm slavery
dude that's as much as an expensive
cookie brother bacon yeah - for real
gases double dues and cookie that's $5
right no
yeoreum you'll work for anything dude
and it's obvious by your getup and some
of the [ __ ] you're always peddling on
your Instagram Stewart well what I'm
saying is what I'm saying is that we
would have to get in this
turned his hotbox that thing to spurn
all the trash down to the ground do we
be at work until 3:00 a.m. putting out a
fire in the back making $17 bucked up
due to my mom sometimes would make me
walk home I'll be like we come pick me
up she bike [ __ ] how far is it it was
honestly not joking at that time was
probably 7 miles and you run too now
yeah and so at that time I'd run 7 you
nod leave my apron and everything I
worked in just run that honking seven
I've run it in pants you don't run in
church pants
no hell yeah you got it I'll be running
Church for painters and gasoline
zanzabar shoes huh those Andy Dufresne
work shoes tall black no what are those
ones that Doc Martens do low top all the
low tops dude you want to talk about
cutting and the back of my heels would
be all cut up I mean through the bone
I'm one of my feet I left it on the side
of a road and just ran on one foot to
get home they said I never put a bandaid
on no and I never put a woman's bandaid
on either the cooler my Brennan's
mayonnaise well the cool thing my
Brennan's band-aids statement is that
there than fancy kind that blend well
that's the only color you can get how it
band-aids are racist there's no whatever
do you think this there's only white
people mandates Brown get a mixed B you
can get a mix much they do colored
band-aids really like you can't get an
Asian band-aid you can't get a black
band-aid it's only white person bandit
because we're the only people that use
man is they put like you know whatever
it is we're talking we don't use all
over the under the counter or whatever
it is over the moon medication you use
duct tape no herbivores or whatever what
do you agent people are what not
herbivores you know I'm talking about
yeah aroma therapy aromatherapy young
bees eucalyptus yes pine
field fern have you ever met our cat I
have met cat before when we're through I
didn't think you guys met we saw each
other one time didn't we there we go so
this isn't the first time he has met
nice to see you shoot now she racist or
not is this racist dumbest she refers to
herself as a jungle Asian oh yeah yeah
um I think it's cool me too
that's dumb you know but I'm not a
racist
recovering racist I think but I are you
really a jungle Asian yeah do you know
what jungle Asian is I would say it's
probably I would guess Filipino or
Laotian or something like that are you
gonna get deep Vietnamese yeah Wow
beautiful Vietnamese mm-hmm
you never know Vietnamese sometimes I
thought I one time I met a I thought I
met a Vietnamese guy but it was just a
Mexican guy that I've been in a fire
that's fair though it's a tough and
that's a tough call yeah it's tough for
the skin come in a spectrum yeah
but jungle aging comes from the term
what though because when she said I was
like I feel racist right because you
guys come from the jungle yeah so if me
and teal refer to certain age don't
include me on whatever you're about to
do well you just want a whole rant how
you thought Mixon was a burnt Asian so I
think you're good I also spent aa $60 as
a child to go see a rumored Asian in a
burned-down pizza real quick I've all
seen all Jackie Chan movies so [ __ ] it
what's up is wrist snap at the end of a
whole foods back juicer juice and peanut
Wow dude used to fight he's just a fight
what dude you kind of find it cold now
and struggle and it looks like wow bro
bro you couldn't go two rounds with
who's a real shitty fighter right now CM
Punk yeah dude you think you could beat
CM Punk right now get out get out I'm
serious I know the better question would
be do you think you could beat see I
could if I'm allowed to use if they put
two more ropes on how many ropes are on
the ring well it's an octagon siz no
okay well what if they put extra rope
sometimes okay so let's say you're
fighting them in a WWE W if they go big
cage and they throw some ladders in
there I could do something I think I
feel that because I used to paint and I
was on ladders all the time you know you
know your way around ladder y know my
way up and down fast side to side you
know what I'm saying yeah I'd be around
I'm sort of that a jungle construction
worker whoa
nothing wrong with that well are your
parents from Vietnam yeah
Wow what part um Saigon and yeah have
you been there a lot or no when I was
younger yeah I used to go more often
that's cool it's cool place huh
it's saddest [ __ ]
thanks honey well if tourists tend to go
to the really nice places right fancy
places that's not real is yeah but
that's that's not really but do you find
it like to go with her so I would we
would I sleep on like the ground and
[ __ ] but I would down I'm down to go I
went on as a student one time and they
took us to and a lot of the taxi drivers
and stuff in the beginning it's just
tourist stuff you know they take you to
like a brothel or someplace where
there's women you can meet girls but
this place was a pet shop at a pet shop
in the front and low key in the back
they was doing you know sexual offers
ro-butt and my buddies they were real
perverts you know and I'm in there
looking at these [ __ ] parakeets and
all kind of parrot let there know who
hedgehogs birds mostly dude and it's the
[ __ ] jungle bro hedgehogs the [ __ ]
out of here dude look it's Montana
they had real beautiful animals in there
and everybody else is trying to come in
the back and I'm trying to catch one of
these [ __ ] beautiful parrot lets out
dude you don't think you now do now just
be dead honest do you think you bought a
cheap parrot and they got your dick up
in the bag I dunno what happened they
had some we went in the back and and I
got super nervous and then I left and I
didn't I didn't I and then did your
buddy say go down did they [ __ ] a toucan
of something I don't know how strange
got but the funny thing to me was the
parrots knew a lot of English and they
would mimic a lot of sexual things that
heard you know like you know and it was
so crazy like I cheap they said oh my
guys left why got cheap but I thought it
was beautiful it was so busy that I was
amazed how many people could move around
on motorcycles weren't you just in China
the answers in China did you swing jokes
right very different place no I'm just
saying though its Asia bro yeah you've
been here recently you haven't been to
her part of the [ __ ] world so this is
what it sounds like when I try to weasel
my way out of a racist moment um yes I
have been there but I loved it though I
thought it was cool but yeah I guess
there's some parts where it's like we
went on like the Mekong whatever went on
like boats and like but they just took
it still like touristy stuff like to
hold snakes andele know what the real
thing man
please go anymore though a lot of people
yeah they get robbed too there now it's
a whenever they see a lot of white
people or people who just aren't Asian
they tend to flock there and brought
people really and is so the people that
are robbing people is it just like poor
Vietnamese people that are doing it is
it angry people like is it or is there
any time I think it's mostly poor is it
kids it's yeah kids adults they have a
lot of different scams they have nice
knives or somewhere guns
I saw two motorcycles collide and
another motorcycle came up robbed the
guy of his bag and drove off so two guys
ah yeah so two motorcycles would come
one would crash into somebody with a bag
with oh yeah it's a setup and then
somebody else's friend would come grab
the bag he would drive off another guy
who hit the victim would drive off to do
stuff like that would happen so does a
grand theft auto it sounds like God or
though just like Inc necklaces and stuff
like that
you're shaking right off your neck so
yeah but that's like anywhere here's
always you know every place has its
scams is I think it's just like it and
some countries are still like on foot
whereas here it's more like electronic
electronic scams or you know yeah
somebody will steal your credit card
number at a place and use it you know or
do you ever get those dams like oh
what's up daddy you want to see more
pictures click here yeah I almost want
post like you stupid [ __ ] who is
falling for this [ __ ]
whatever those fake Apple ones like the
emails it's like call now come on dude
call now who the [ __ ] fall for this
but I guess it works all the time how
did you meet cat how did you end up with
these guys cat I graduated college
needed a job
Deanne Brennan and asked him if he
needed an intern but how long ago that's
a while she was she did it right when
she graduate from USC right yeah SC and
then she did it a while ago that was
June and that I came back from the Bay
Area and that eidm do you again and then
I ended up here she's a little beef yeah
I think imported me straight from
Vietnam ya know i'm see how they say it
vietnam yeah you didn't know that bro I
know that really yeah I knew that
Vietnam I forgot it but I know it yeah I
needed to learn more I probably I'm
thinking about learning another line
which boy died I need you a little more
worldly you know I'm saying Oh like I
want to go rob people with them out
there dude where are you you already
look like you look like all of the who's
the Fratellis from you look like every
one of the Fratellis who's the Fratellis
from you look Lebanese you look like mom
and sell rats
you look again on the side of the river
that sell rat do you look like something
that's gonna audition to be one of the
Bugle Boy that what's the who the people
that robbed Scrooge McDuck well who were
those guys that big guy with the beagle
boys the beagle boys they were dope yeah
duck de Bordeaux yeah they were dope man
costume there they are the big oh my god
oh yeah that's my squad bro the Beagle
boys I wonder where chris d'elia is at
dude he's probably just rich dude
someone said he has four sofas in his
house oh what a piece of [ __ ] at least
there's people that don't have sofas
like in other countries were cats from
and even maybe we're probably where I'm
from dude Louisiana has other smaller
countries yeah
Louisiana some of the most Vietnamese
people in America too pretty cool is
that true yeah cuz a lot of enemies
people tend to go to New Orleans to be
what is a fisherman they would rent bad
boys yeah then those shrimp sandwiches
we're gon pool boys oh yeah they're nice
but yeah Vietnamese they love being be
any people we need anything you can go
to some of the markets I remember
they'll kill her right in front of you
yep everything in anything you ever you
every one of those eggs that the bit
means work with uh uh you know when I'm
eggs I brought hot eggs or something
it's like a [ __ ] velociraptor egg and
it's a dead baby bird in the middle they
drink the juice and Oh Baloo duck egg
yeah I think that's it boy would you eat
that deal me neither
I can't and I can't eat that now if you
throw it one day now if asthma wilson
[ __ ] motor up and throws a couple onto
pizza I will eat it depends what kind of
people Americans with anything on pizza
but alone they won't eat it that's the
interesting thing
yeah got deep-dish there might be little
hide one of those in there on me
things got a little bit of ovary left on
the back end of it because I can't [ __ ]
oh you would you'd eat that cat right
now I wouldn't eat the bird I only eat
the yolk and sip the broth but who is
feeling that baby bird oh yeah crying
the dead bird out of the [ __ ] water
Wow man from my cold dead egg dying is
bad
Wow so people don't eat the bird they
toss the bird people eat the bird and
our Vietnamese people very our
Vietnamese people very sexual or not yes
we put a bikini on girls all the time
really have you been to have enemies
coffee shop before no I over in Orange
County I don't think you have yeah I
think you're thinking of something else
it's they have a lot in Orange County in
San Jose where it's basically like a
hooters a Starbucks in a strip club had
a baby
oh no I oh wow and where's that at you
said Orange County they have a lot of
moms on women Orange County no they have
a bunch of Orange County San Jose and
you where where there's a little no do
you see any of enemies people here
besides me yeah no I don't need a lot of
Koreans yeah in store for chin stuff and
there's no there's no [ __ ] tie I'm
sorry is there's no vet Me's
coffee shop you got what on your way you
gotta stop by my definite go now
so I can get a dark roast dick-suck yeah
do you girls make Bank though they do
yeah
and our Vietnamese people are very they
they love business or very business
minded yes we're very conservative but
also we love them like this right but
most I don't mean interrupt or be racist
there now most Asian all don't want to
do both right most Asian cultures aren't
very sexual that's really very taboo
yes Wow they don't talk about sex but
they're both always loved bro right oh
that's interesting
now they don't talk about sex because
that mean that that like within their
own families and culture things very
sexual or it's or do you feel like a
mirror like America it seems a lot more
sexualized uh as people or Americans I'm
just curious
Brian said in the Asian culture Swiss
Japanese the walls are so thin so when
you'd have sex you you know is quiet oh
yeah like with
yeah Oh [ __ ] oh they had the bird oh
[Laughter]
it's not spoken about in the household
but when you walk around the culture is
basically like this
we're not culture
yeah and you guys they joke about a lot
more stuff like Americans seem like very
sensitive up and yeah joke about these
days yeah whereas I find that like
people from other cultures are like a
lot more open loosey goose I can't do
that show JK news sometimes oh and those
kids joke about they don't get what is
it bro they would tell jokes we won't
even say because I don't give a [ __ ]
because they're just normal people
they're not like worried about [ __ ] like
really are yeah a really good example of
what Asians actually are and of like not
being politically correct who and who
are these gentlemen
JK news they have it's a bar Quan and
his wife his name Gio and then they have
my boy Joe Jitsu collar right there on
the left and then they have Melanie
maybe in the middle no Tiffany
attractive girl in the middle and that's
David so and now this is a joke because
they know David sighs David says that
funny he is Korean on the right he grew
up his parents used to sell black hair
care products so he's a personality
oh-ha larry is he a comic too he is a
comedian but there's no it's funny but
dude I went over there and I'm always
like afraid to say stuff and they just
say whatever they don't give a [ __ ] bro
you know who they are - they're big and
they're nice man they're really really
nice people - I love it and they have
like yes I business but yeah they're
very in Jin what does it call when you
do business engine ingenuity I don't
know something anyway who seems more
racist you think fingerprint and that's
really what I say deal by a long shot
really but you're wearing camo dude this
is your camo wookie these are enough
camo capris on these aren't jeans capris
on they was some with some Under Armour
shoes with nike socks camel women capris
and a woman's hair what [ __ ] row you
have a
everything you can only get from being a
cafeteria female cafeteria worker who's
abusing steroids lately on the job you
bro you look like you make sloppy joe
there's me like that you look like you
make the best sloppy joe in LA right now
you look like you raised two kids named
sloppy joe dude if you [ __ ] lose both
you lasted two girls named Diane what
are you talking about dude I'm growing
this for a kid dude who has cancer but
also has a four-wheeler that kid's gonna
be cool as [ __ ] bro locks for lust bro
that's what I'm growing this [ __ ] out
9 year old with no way [ __ ] who's
definitely low in the chromosomes but
he's down the [ __ ] and not afraid to go
in a 5 wheel drive but I've cut my hair
for the dude we're doing I'm just saying
you look like a blatant lesbian
cafeteria worker you have women's blend
in with the [ __ ] leg I didn't create
safety pads I didn't create these
[ __ ] band-aid
bro and they're racist right I didn't do
that I just want to cover up my blisters
bro your blisters your laser you mom
haircut when and your judgment and your
racist ways Pizza insulting the whole
finally kid team he talk does they look
different than Domino's what is it it's
a board game for children you're in
there eating what a [ __ ] creep
there's kids and they're playing games
and you're and they're looking for
[ __ ] black olive in mushroom what a
pervert bro it's not even literally
somebody put pizza flavoring in a can
and sprayed it inside of a [ __ ] but
they're good people there but anyway
what I was saying was earlier is that
there was a story I was telling the
beginning of this I've never gotten to
finish about Asians no you you're you
were oh you're gonna buy a penguin but
you're in jacked off by a young Asian in
the back we're where were we where were
we weren't they only at parity they only
had exotic bird didn't have penguins
they didn't have crow like cold country
birds these were more hot country bird
that's disappointing you know we could
buy a penguin I said looked it up you
can buy them online you know what the
problem is they slap they do yeah they
slap mmm they don't bite they slap you
think you could beat a penguin in a
fight oh that's where we're at could you
be seeing pump really though because
Punk's been training and also both you
guys get penalized for pulling the hair
out of your face
not shave my head effective okay yeah
would you really for sure and what else
would you do would you hit you have to
come out with a new name you can't be
Brendan Schaub again you got to come out
with a new fighting in because everybody
seems like oh I beat this guy so you
have to come out with a new fighting
name what would it be you have to have a
nickname too I would never fight dude
really never do you think he's still
having in your spine to do it like is it
because at some point it had to be like
a you have to be fur you have to be in
an attack mode right I mean yeah yeah
[ __ ] but right now CM Punk could you do
you think you could go to a draw with
him he has a long legs dude how long
were his legs but can you look that up
Jen's insulting CM Punk has been
training bro he's from where Chicago
it's a dangerous city I'm headed to
Chicago are you really yeah Thursday no
I don't mean it as a fence I just mean
it is look how long his legs are 70
inches 73-inch reach bro it does say his
strength is jiu-jitsu on the skill
breakdown
it doesn't he's thirty nine thirty and
jogo
he's young bro it's going some current
events oh and there's the answer it's
inappropriate to ask or not but I'd
watch the fight would you watch it on
pay-per-view chin I gotta ask that
carefully
probably not of course children watch it
bro he just said no dude
out of respect why you just Witten oh
you wouldn't want to see it you said him
and gets Brennan yeah yeah so out of
respect
see I'm plugging his burning but Brennan
also has a cheat code where Brian pops
up on his shoulder and can jump off of
them and do kicks okay I wish Brian's in
New York doing god-knows-what right now
huh who knows bro who knows right
probably looking for penguin probably
looking for some me too claims what else
we have me to Honduras bro who are they
me to hunters dudes like trying to get
my kit right oh you know some guys feel
left out about it just trying to that
publicity and Brian fighting to I keep
hearing about it
Brian says he's always ready to go
Chin's been training we got shirts made
we all sorts of I'm the per mom the Don
king of this thing you are and it's such
it's like trying to make Conor kebede
happen bro it's exhausting who do you
think could win in the fight I'll doing
any of this my boy Dustin Poirier
against our Nate Diaz great fight be a
great fight huh ah do you think it's
actually gonna happen
yeah for sure it is yeah Wow Joe invited
me to go with him I got a performing
buffalo that night you had the helium
they're great yeah so just know that
well oh what's that
have you been there before you know
great club I never been I'm gonna
Charlotte in two weeks though with the
strap comedies oh yeah been there yeah
how was it great yeah great spot um big
yeah congressmen's big great spot though
yeah it's um we got some it's some
pretty good tickets and uh but yeah but
Buffalo one my favorites things I've
done comedy really I love Buffalo just
be friends of JP lo ceman oh yeah a
quarterback did he I went there to visit
him one time I went to see a game cuz he
went to Tulane wait you're there we're
in Buffalo you said next week no I'm
gonna Buffalo in like November so it
might be snowy is [ __ ]
oh yeah no that's the worst I'll bring
you guys like some snow to calve from
Vietnam do them have snow from their
source no bro they have homemade so
didn't snow cut yes I've been to the
snow before we're born here you're born
with yeah dude Wow I've been in other
the Trail of Tears Brendan talking to
anybody from another country food it is
unlike well I don't know like a lot of
people in Southern Cal you know before
yeah dude like pound ok black girls
never seen snow bro dude I'll give you
three guesses what does this mean a lot
I don't know I get in the back why you
think I'm a kidnapper right now bro I
don't know what it means dude well we
used to play this game me and my buddies
we had a Japanese guy that we met in
college and we would make sounds and see
if it was something most racist thing of
the day no way give him the award for
the most racist thing in the day yeah
tall and even like dude that means
working cloud cover
that means heavy cloud cover that's so
much Japanese whether you like Nara
oh but before you incur evanthia piss
hard let's take a break all right
Kizzy Lorant the toughest [ __ ] man
I've ever met with this woman Kizzy
Lorant my god dude you gonna jump over a
volleyball net dude oh yeah yeah I mean
she was tough as hell and she has a son
now actually he's a dick he just guy
he's playing College he might be playing
at George or something but he was a
beast a beast he was like the top
running back in uh in Louisiana last
year laughs in Frenette no Broomfield is
his name no he's still in he just got
out of high school word get some
convention oh [ __ ] well you guys go Ric
Flair just got married this past week
and a clip of him walking out to Brooke
Hogan it's the girl who used to play his
maid back in the day when he used to do
WWF you got a gimmick where he had like
a girl that dressed up in a French maid
outfit he's marrying her cuz he's so
rich he had a man yeah and he's walking
out to the Miko song ric flair drip so
this was circulating so when she was in
the video - Wow yeah it sounds hit it
Jim oh this is Chris D'Elia fast-forward
40 years this is Chris D'Elia
this is awkward is that Brooke Hogan no
that's his daughter there's not young as
Charlotte
Herman smile doesn't he
oh yeah it looks like a hairdryer just
[ __ ] will not leave him alone today's
invocation all the time Dundee he's on
medication at this point looks like
weekend at Bernie's or some [ __ ] that's
pretty swag dude you swag you for sure
oh definitely what else you got now that
guy can keep it up near the interstate
that's a real man dude there should be a
test on if you can keep an erection how
close to the interstate you can keep it
dude that's mainly a lot of Peschel ala
a lot of people I bet they wouldn't [ __ ]
40 yards from a highway where I'm from
dude you keep an erection right up next
you can feel the [ __ ] traffic go by
oh I'm real man I'll get his dick hit by
a [ __ ] rearview mirror Wow and still
[ __ ] after bro if you can keep an
erection near a car going 7080 miles an
hour that's a man if you think Rick
fuller can do that no not anymore I
think in his heyday you're right I think
Arn Anderson could he was low-key quiet
but seemed like he had all dick on him
anyway
I feel like answering Cooper can really
yeah you seem in that storm you see them
Anderson Cooper yeah you see man that's
that storm bro the storm it's just like
it dude it's it's totally it's 11 gay
interns
spraying really intense spray bottles on
him from the side and you think he's
just in LA filming Oh wet what's that
guy's name again Wes Anderson what's his
name
Emerson Cooper yeah David that's what
say Anderson Anderson Cooper's whatever
I'm not a bit I'm not not an innocent
Cooper fan but he's to his best work
ever was when he who's a host on a show
called the mole a long time ago that
real on ABC yeah and that was his best
work ever
I just don't trust the news I don't
trust any of them so then you have to
dislike him though why he's [ __ ]
working for them yeah but he's not he
doesn't create the news and the [ __ ]
hurricanes and [ __ ] but a man he's just
his job that's like so you know I know I
don't know what chin told us hey won't
you tell a bunch of a young man out in
the world a bunch of complete [ __ ]
to make them feel uncertain about their
lives
I'd like I'm not doing that dude I'd
rather do something else bro I'm saying
train turtles are you saying there's
there's no hurricane you think he's
making that up I'm not so now whether
that's an easy one for him do but
outside of that man it's just a bunch of
[ __ ] rhetoric and a bunch of [ __ ]
Mulan's out there bunch of mooks dude
guys Joey Diaz would never talk to
[ __ ] Don lemons or whatever that song
mix puppet get that [ __ ] tart out of
here dude do guys never had an original
idea in his head in another let's check
the racist box from that one the mix you
can take that one I'll take that one I
don't know what that is I'm homeless
Nicaraguan dude so if he wants to go
races with me let's go bro racist Rain
bro dude my father my father was born in
Nicaragua bro live there Lee was 17 so
let's [ __ ] go Don lemons dude lemons
bro do you hate Don Lemon I just think
they're I don't like those guys that are
just like any of them that are [ __ ]
you know whatever that guy's name is
lucky Carlson or whatever the other
neither lucky Karl's let me ask you this
where do you get your news from brah
where do you get your news from I'll
look at both man I'll look at any of
them CNN Fox you don't look at him I
used to look at him and I was probably
probably more Fox but then it just got
to the point where it's just they're
both kind of it's just like a pure hate
fest on the other one I don't want
either means right that's the thing now
it's not news and you know now it's now
it's it's like tabloids I get my news
from right here Charlotte Flair with
this [ __ ] Ric Flair showing up to
that drip drip
dude I'm happy to know he's alive the
crazy thing is he looks dead if you look
at him
yeah he looks like he's in bald with
raccoon hands well that's on the same
when you died get those [ __ ] to get
the hands up dude I want a wig Doh huh I
want a wig I've already got a wig bro
okay you can't talk about somebody's
here well you have you Bri Alison 70s
haircut bro I got the only person I know
with this haircut that's a lie I got the
power in the front I got the glory in
the bag dude I'm just a sharecropper
brother let's be in the back and the
dick in the food gods grow a Sun dude if
your [ __ ] haircut was a choice on
great clips no one would think of no one
besides lesbian oh dude beautiful let's
take the field cut lesbians dude right
now
and the crazy thing is you are all my
might have the hair you have all the
other elements of a [ __ ] real lesbian
dude do you have the hair and the face
no you tell me your nose doesn't look
lesbian I knows I have a nose of a
brother do - straight up
oh brother no brothers I've ever seen uh
be black Greek guy no ho yeah little say
czar bruh and feel me beats a [ __ ]
Pizza [ __ ] oh wow okay little say hard
say that we're the [ __ ] black Greek
boys at that little saison says our on
we're dude what else you got chin yeah
okay so revolve released a bunch of
sweaters with things like being fat is
not beautiful and and went viral a lot
of people are angry at revolve for this
but letters
well the sweaters if you look at the
bottom it seems like everyone who's
outraged in it look at the very bottom
of the sweater it says as said to and
then a model or an influencers name this
is a part of a campaign with five
celebrities where they take the worst
comment they've ever gotten
put it on sweaters and then says like as
said to or whatever that's going down a
dangerous road
yeah and a lot of people are angry about
it because they didn't see the bottom
and realize that it was supposed to be a
campaign against bullying and yeah I
mean the giant letters says being fat is
not butyl it's an excuse which I agree
with but did you see what are some
people it's there a it's okay for them
why can't it just be there are some
people like it some people don't
you know I think that's what it is
probably but but I think I think it
stems from to is like glorifying obese
people being like everything's beautiful
it's like well yeah but that's super
unhealthy like you you're gonna die
early and there's obesity problem in
America so yeah cool if you want to be
fat that's cool but I don't know if we
should glorify it so so you're in
support of the sweater or not I wouldn't
buy the sweater you even in no way I
wanna buy the sweater
you wouldn't know really you wouldn't
buy the sweater you seem like a guy that
would buy one bro I would not buy some
like the dude that buys everything bro
everyday I see of an yeah different pair
of [ __ ]
shoes on look like British shoes or
something like he this guy's feet living
Britain and his body lives here in
America you're gonna [ __ ] yellow do
you know where this comes from
you know wheelchair airforces or
whatever the legit you have yeah
Benedict Arnold x9s or whatever all this
[ __ ] I want some Benedict Arnold XD so
orange candy come on [ __ ] you know
keyless entry [ __ ] low tops like what
the [ __ ] is going on bro bro you have a
[ __ ] Juwanna
Sacajawea [ __ ] disband on right now
with one made this for me yet I'm save
America a Native American make that play
yeah no we're anything anything anyone
gives you you with I remember yeah any
that is somebody gives me yeah yeah on
that hand-me-down bad boy you know what
I'm saying I mean you're [ __ ] dead
step-grandfather this [ __ ] favorite
jacket you know what I'm saying put me
in that [ __ ] dude I'll be in y'all
being you step wife's [ __ ] mercy
goodwill so yeah first he will down set
hand me dance dude here's we mall art
here was this here's what I was telling
you so there was a fire when I learned
play charades so there was a fire and
these kids are playing the guys in a
wheelchair playing I didn't know how the
game was and so I started guessing I
thought it's guest movies that this guy
could be in so I guessed cuz you said
silence of the limbs and I remember you
said something earlier cuz this guy his
list some of his limbs wasn't Isis you
know fully functional so I remember
guessing silent to the limbs I remember
guessing a Forrest Gump that's one thing
I felt horrible because I don't know how
the game was I thought they put the guy
in the middle I guess what movies this
guy could be in because people are
yelling out you know
dances a wolf people yelling out like
Dan you know like I don't remember what
else I yelled out Oh bridge just spina
bifida I remember guessing and that's
the one that [ __ ] met her own
feelings afterward but I didn't know you
thought of his movies he could be like
yes they're like oh you know what could
Lawrence being you know and Lawrence is
in a wheelchair you know and I was like
oh these are that's a funny game
yeah things your way yeah yeah like of
my semi team oh it's kind of hurtful but
dude I can't wait to see the meme of you
in of mice and mossy no I can't see you
in the sequel of - fun - you read that
[ __ ] movie so uh so yeah I think
pizza it's the winner when it comes to
pizza and I don't give a [ __ ] about that
sweatshirt no I'm not good either so a
school in China welcomes back all of
their students as well as their parents
to the first day of school with pole
dancers thanks what an American army
jobs an American writer was taking his
child to school on the first day saw
this recorded it put it on Twitter and
it went viral after this happened he
went home told his wife and his wife
called the headmaster to see why there
were a bunch of pole dancers at the
school and had the headmistress end up
hanging up on her butt saying it's good
exercise
hmm what fine it is and also in China
there's not a lot of room to exercise so
you can find yeah so to use a pole to
get it done as opposed to doing
something else with more long form but I
think it's little you don't think that's
a stretch deal well here in America we
don't teach them about it and then half
them end up doing it for money you know
kids aren't interested they understand
what's going on they're not thinking you
know people are gonna give this lady
money and try to [ __ ] her in the parking
lot later you know they're thinking that
oh here's a woman doing a piece of
performance there's a woman burning some
calories right
yeah I wonder what do you guys think
about that this is one of the most
Chinese things I've ever seen
yeah really yeah I saw a guy feed a
booger to a cat when I was in Shanghai
it makes me feel now is awesome I
thought really yeah well to them it's
just nothing goes on wasted it to you
this is going to this cat or this is
going in a soup you know in China if
your buddy dies next you on the street
you [ __ ] chop him up bro you chop
them up in my ear and then you and the
rest your buddies eating you cruise and
that's what I respect about Chinese it's
like they keep moving it's like let's
keep moving on recognized scene here an
unprecedent way yeah
and in Marion I'm afflictive all the
feeling [ __ ] you know I'm out here
on these sertraline tablets you know
yeah bro and that's generic [ __ ]
Zoloft [ __ ] it feel good on it
no I don't feel good on it but I have to
take it so I don't [ __ ] lose my mind
in the afternoon and cry my car off the
interstate so that's where I am I'm
American what else saying I feel you bro
you stay on the no you don't feel me to
give on how many yeah I think assistance
pads do you basically have one has an ID
I didn't create these [ __ ] band-aids
America did I want them to be black yes
sure you king or sting these band-aids
broke if you had a king king immersed in
this Rat King [ __ ] all day bro and look
at the title belt right here something
Chris D'Elia will never have dude and he
can have all kind of stuff he has
someone said in his house he has a ice
cream maker and someone said that that
is a Slurpee machine Oh crystal he has
an ice cream maker in his house and
doesn't even eat dairy that's why I'm
just there well that's that's
overabundance and that's rich people
doing rich [ __ ] someone city has for
couches dude and there's a man out there
and a woman out there trying to make
love on a floor somewhere while that
[ __ ] sitting there were four
couches well dude the only ain't a champ
bony never will be
oh [ __ ] and you know it come see him
daliyah huh
come see me dude he's too busy doing you
know doing whatever he does do him
rich Oh being rich dude someone said he
got a jacket made out of money made a
bunch of just made by a jacket made out
of money you know it's crazy he wanders
around his house hiding money probably
around and then blindfold himself and
going looking for his own dude I saw
Chris microwave a wad of cash before
yeah
microwaving he's changed man when I met
him he was a different guy whose gentle
nice cared about his animals
someone said his animals he has like a
group a pet company that comes and takes
him and he just brings him around for
his Instagram oh dude and him and Bobby
Lee this is a true story you should go
down to Mexico
Chris and my beliefs you got into Mexico
to get involved with who knows what but
they used to go watch Mexican comedians
perform and steal their material and
bring it back up to America how crazy is
that difference fighting words and they
would steal the Mexican means we talk in
Spanish they translate and steal back
America who knows what happened dude
that I'm just telling you what I've
heard and this is just around the water
huh
that's around the water this around the
water cooler but I'll say this there's a
lot of people drinking around the wallet
water cool yeah the water crews be Nancy
Scott is Ali Wong if you guys are going
to the Comedy Store
hey you don't code everybody [ __ ]
knows dude don't say that uh sorry it's
not it's something it's a puma Thurman
or whatever fake name is what else the
judge in I don't know so there's a
school in Georgia that set out a bunch
of permission slips for the ability to
basically paddle kids when they're in
trouble so parents can opt out of it and
if parents opt out then the kids who get
in trouble can face a five-day
suspension instead mm-hmm don't touch my
kid really [ __ ] no but here's a crazy
thing when you as a child you know
whenever that was 50 years ago but when
you were a child um you'll get even home
school tinge or 30 yeah did I taught
myself for two years at the house
because the BART the bus in our town was
broken it was there only a racist Bible
or was it dude our Bible had pictures
people in it and a lot of the pictures
were black no a lot of people were black
in the Bible that's cool and also we
made them black too because they're men
yep because we didn't want them to be
it's like all there's way too many white
drawings do weird [ __ ] bro
we were verily right very racially
diverse
ugly racist yeah it's kind of weird
because the protocol for paddling kids
is that they will take them and paddle
them in private is what their words are
which to me just reminds me about it so
how and what is this elementary middle
school it's a charter school I believe
it's elementary to middle school Wow I
like that that's my kid son but then
here's the thing your kid is gonna okay
then that's fine that's the choice
you're making but then your child is
gonna be that child at school that is
afraid to get powder afraid to [ __ ]
take it like a champ
you know what I'm saying you're saying
this by knowing that thing it hit it
enforce them to stay in line I'm saying
yes I think that and also I think it
makes him have respect for the other
kids in school like you know I'm saying
Larry we'll get you know paddled [ __ ]
dell'arte he'll get paddled
you know both of his parents so you're
going through it together
so y'all are going through it together
and then meanwhile your kid chariot or
whatever your son's name is yeah chariot
won't you know they said they got it if
he gets crazy they just you know put him
in a cot you know talk to him yeah yeah
put him in a you know seven thousand
seven thousand print cotton suit and
leave him out in the yard or something
you know something soft or relax and
give him a grapefruit slice yeah I don't
mind a nice watch and give him a great
food slice and give him some of that big
brown coffee or whatever that watching
him afresh yeah now if he has to drink a
fresca really fast that is desolate dude
we should torture terrace with fresca
yeah let me know how your day goes and
if your eyes what are you getting gunned
down yeah yeah yeah oh dude imagine that
bro drink up fresca without your eyes
water can you guys have fresca
gin cat I've never had fresca yeah it's
Americans after drinking sometimes when
their parents think that they're old
enough to drink adult yeah and they're
not and it's I love it I grew it I think
it's very refreshing my mom used to
drink um I love a fresca [ __ ]
challenging the listeners try downing a
fresco all in one yeah without blinking
your eyes yes that dudes impossible oh
that's that straight-up fresca it's
refreshing
yeah it's called fresh cup is it yeah
it's good I think I think it's better in
other countries I think at the American
fresca the shit's a little bit harsh and
like the road yeah it's kind of like
Guinness in Dublin delicious here that's
all right yeah yeah don't touch my kid
though really no but here's the thing
though were you ever paddled at school
by a principal never it's actually legal
in nineteen states right now to hit kids
in school no no no no mmm and I bet a
lot of those states are awesome as [ __ ]
do we know what states those are I think
New Orleans but here's the thing I guess
New Orleans Florida a lot of south and
New Orleans is in a state okay a lot of
South is in a state Louisiana [ __ ] in
general Brendan wants new to rivers only
in the entire world dude that's fast
before I knew a lot more and you're
racist so I win that racist bro dude
does more twenty states that still pal
cuticles Wyoming of course Wyoming Utah
Colorado yeah I grew up there's no one
hit me
Arizona makes sense they didn't hit you
they thought you were working at the
cafeteria just make sense
they're like meh i oh wow yep you go and
chin ohio do where JT barrow is from
burrow sorry i plucked the same up but
LSU new quarterback hey me [ __ ] did I
die Barrett was the quarterback for Ohio
State
yeah keep going alright keep going keep
going
a lot of tight New Mexico Mexico sorry
doc point you guys anyone know where
Mexico keep going
Florida told your ass Kentucky told your
ass Cato century SEC in the house Texas
Georgia South yep Tennessee mouth
Louisiana hell yeah I got spanked my
Lawton McKee I'll tell you this dude
Lawton
he said he at one of his teeth was in
front of the other one directly in front
of it bruh you know I'm saying he had
that [ __ ] he was running that 2-5
defense in his mouth you know that front
I formation and I fear baseball back in
the front oh yeah I know that a party in
the back
you know the wish man he said and I
remember people would ask me what I have
missed you thing he said he swung that
paddle so hard that his [ __ ] teeth it
did [ __ ] shook his whole face up and
knock his teeth in front of each other
but that dude spanked me one time in his
office and when you came back from the
principal it was [ __ ] up but it was
also people were like damn bro you got
some respect
you got some respect kind of
embarrassing off it was embarrassing but
there was a level of respect with it
because you you made it through it yeah
like damn I do can get paddled I and it
made you see I don't want to get paddled
no I'm gonna keep my [ __ ] together at
work now imagine there's no discipline
in schools what's gonna happen to you
nothing think about that nothing is
gonna happen
well maybe we still expect our teachers
to give a [ __ ] when these [ __ ] kids
are running around you know so you want
to start hitting - I'm not saying
started hitting him and I I don't think
and discipline without hitting him yeah
and you can also just one without be a
molester dude we had a great disc
Lawton McKee a great man he was a family
man and he spanked kids when they also
molested kids he didn't molest anybody
dude I just assume in Louisiana
molesting kids no bro you're from
Colorado do you know much easier it is
to molest a kid at high off easier is
undernourished with you on how easy is
to molest a kid in Louisiana and that's
thick moisture air you call barely in
your hand close to them they're so thick
no time your hand gets close because
it's lame it on alligators down there I
know you guys do it bro no an alligator
touch this kid's dick nobody's believing
that an alligator would bite that thing
right off slap it with its tail bro fish
that suck kids off I don't about most of
our catfish these are from Vietnam did a
lot of our market is going abroad
another racist races out now all cafes
are from Vietnam most of them are and
that's we fish now I think how do you
say it in Vietnamese yeah I have no idea
what you call catfish but binamis people
do you catfish a lot yeah don't lead it
right up
bro in Vietnamese people swim in the
water with their mouths open and come up
full and that's beautiful
well they are I mean they are of the
earth brah they know how to get it done
the Vietnamese people die they don't
make a big deal about it I don't even
tell anybody they just die it's not in
the paper or nothing well it's just like
we here we bother everybody we make sure
there's one last you got a dress up and
[ __ ] go to their funeral black there's a
Facebook group yeah we're on HootSuite
an hour before our drip bag died you
know the morphine sets in you know
sending out one Lance going live on
Instagram before we pass away yeah
everybody's just bothering everybody
with their eyes yes go Vietnamese died
reincarnated an hour later they're a
wolf up in the [ __ ] you know bow on
the dry part [ __ ] parent in a sex
shop it's beautiful yeah and it is
beautiful yeah so last week was Fashion
Week and usually Fashion Week ends with
Marc Jacobs show but this year he was
bumped by Rihanna's Fenty lingerie show
damn and Marc Jacobs is actually
notorious for always starting on time
this year his show was at 6 o'clock
and it ran one hour and 17 minutes late
and Rihanna's show starts at 7:30 so a
lot of people are speculating that he
made the show even later and later and
later in order to get back at Rihanna
he was so late that editor started to
get up and leave in order to get to
Brooklyn to Rihanna show and Anna
Wintour almost left as well mm-hmm over
in Rihanna show a lot of people are
appraising her because she had a diverse
group of models she even have pregnant
models one of the models actually went
into labor while she was doing the show
finished the show and then went to the
hospital yeah and the baby tripped on
the runway on the way out her vagina
laughs um I saw the pictures of the
pregnant model I don't like is it on her
chin to me it was uncomfortable I don't
think it's comfortable to think that
while you're trying to enjoy a fashion
show somebody's gonna go into labor I
don't know if that is that modeling or
is it just sometimes there's so much
stuff to make a statement it's like it's
not a station shock factor like right
but can we talk factor but are you cool
with fat models like obese models yeah
I'm okay with any type of models and I'm
okay with a model being pregnant if a
model is this close to having a baby it
can't mean safe it can't be safe that's
the thing but if that baby drops right
out you know and then the baby ends up
having a dead brain damage and it's
handicapped for the rest of its life but
it has free Fendi because of this
[ __ ] or free lingerie because of the
fashion line you know what I'm wearing
right now
these pants are got in Shanghai at a
train stop yeah I've been there too
small yep way too small and they looked
bigger on the man the man I bought him
off of the man dude off the mannequin
well the ones he had were smaller and
then he had on bigger ones and he sold
me those and I felt bad they were hot
when I put them on my leg so that's the
guy she's got them Shanghai hot pants
dude yeah all right Vontae Davis quit
his team Buffalo Bills halfway through
the game did you see this yeah on the
team quit did you see the game no I say
at least he left the stadium seat at the
drink see guys [ __ ] suck I'm out so
want a deuce you don't his brother is uh
Terrell Davis no no his brother ident
Vernon Davis right so absolute [ __ ]
freak I think
for the Redskins now but here's a baller
for the 49ers forever
I'd like the most impressive combine
numbers anyways this dude at halftime
said you know what y'all suck I'm out
well here's my thought ones all up in
arms about him like what do you think
it's a [ __ ] move to do to your
teammates for sure like Ellie at least
go through the game in the naphthene guy
god I can't do this you mom
what are you supportive you don't
support it I think you should be able do
where the [ __ ] you want to do and
professional sports so cutthroat I'm
always taking the players side here
so infuse like I don't do the same with
the scheme sucks I don't feel like doing
this or I don't like the coaches I like
the team why go through it for a half
right get out get the [ __ ] out yeah it's
sometimes you have those moments where
it's just like this isn't for me and you
know it in that moment you go through it
anyway imagine him playing the second
half and not wanting to be a part of it
I've had that happen in sports and
football in fighting rounds like I don't
want to do this anymore
yeah but you cannot back out right like
you literally can't bat you have to do
it that's awful is it really did you
ever go into a fight and you had to
fight you didn't want to or my last
fight I've only had to happen twice my
last fight which was like five years ago
and then when I fought right now so I
was like I just don't want to do this I
don't want to it
why I don't want to go out right now in
fight oh that would be so tough man the
worst that would be so tough yeah yeah I
can't imagine that I mean I know
feelings of like I don't want to go on
stage and perform but it's not like
having it be so physical you can get
through it right right and also I can
let's say tonight I set the comic store
if I'm like [ __ ] I don't feel like doing
this I can go up there get through it
might not be my best effort then
tomorrow night come back and revamp
myself and get up for it yeah fighting
it's like [ __ ] man yeah put 12 weeks
into this everyone's watching there's
people in the stands there's a whole
ordeal it's the worst mm-hmm yeah
minutes while dude but yeah if you got
to go man you got to go what else you
got so the some of his tweets his prior
tweets started resurfacing after he
retired and they're all basically
they're all pretty much like you should
never quit I says the people who succeed
in life for those who don't quit in
capital letters that's hilarious hmm
successful people keep moving they make
mistakes along the way but they never
quit money when you come pick your son
up boy to
I don't want to retire early never quit
use each setback each disappointment as
the cue to push ahead with the
determination than ever before yeah I
mean those into I'm 13 2012 yeah yeah I
mean that's how he felt at this time and
then now he's gonna do it not so all
right so the guy playing behind them
chomping at the bit to get playing time
you're really going the wrong way and
it's also I'm so sick of and this is
Annunaki you pulling this up this is a
knock to whoever made this thing it's
like you can't hold someone's all of
someone's past like like they have this
new I was talking about this on on this
past weekend today but it's like they
have this Supreme Court justice and
they're bringing up something happened
to him in high school like an alleged
sexual assault in high school not a rape
not a nothing that was ever charged or
went to cry nothing like that an alleged
moment between two drunk teenagers right
at a house party school and in high
school old is he now this is 35 years
ago and that's why now he can't be a
Supreme Court justice and that's [ __ ]
ridiculous dude that's [ __ ]
ridiculous that's ridiculous maybe but
it's the same type of stuff it's
bringing up how you felt eight years ago
into this moment today it's the same
type of thing with like blaming people
for [ __ ] that happened 40 years ago you
know but also I mean obviously rape is
rape if you rape sonship yeah you know
challenged but if they're like oh he
treated me like [ __ ] 30 years ago like
[ __ ] now I'm a different dude that was
two years ago a men ever do that was
five years ago
that's the thing I know it's very
strange and it but it's not real though
it's fake it's like this but I also
think it's a way of people to bring
other people down cuz then point and go
oh look here you said this there's like
dude I was 22 when I said that yeah I'm
a grown man now but it's the same it's
the same way people want to paint you
into these boxes like oh well he used to
be a football player he's a football
player he has to play football right and
Dave's like no I don't want to do that
anymore man I'm gonna do this over here
now right it was like nope we look at
you like this he's like yeah but I'm
doing this now right so it's just yeah
and it's like yeah I don't know this is
just like there's moments here it's like
you can change and if we'd only allow
people to change you know and here's the
crazy thing the same people would argue
that oh kids need to have second
chances in schools when they're young
yeah so it's the same people saying kids
should have second chances when schools
when they're young we need to have
better schooling and better
opportunities for them you know in case
things happen to them where they can get
through it and deal with it but then to
bring up something happened 35 years ago
to somebody it's same with like the the
quarterback that drafted Allen there I
go when when he was in high school look
at the racist tweets he sent out yeah
here's like him bullshitting with his
friend that's like dude he was 16 yeah
so you're gonna you're gonna drop drop
this man the draft because I mean 16
thinker for you at social me or 16 you
didn't really mean half the [ __ ] he said
is he really racist probably not yeah
should should it be brought to his
attention like dude look what the [ __ ]
you said you like oh my god I'm sure you
watch your comedy special about how many
years ago is that yeah three or four
years here I go my god what the [ __ ]
some stuff yeah that it's not I'm not
saying it's bad yeah who is a person
when you look back on old [ __ ] you do
you're like oh [ __ ] I can't believe I
said that I can't believe I came up with
that bit yeah no I'm saying like you
look at stuff you like dude I would do
it completely different if I was doing
it today yeah I mean that comment I
suppose of the no offense coming so it
was pretty bad I'll say that but no no
no I'm saying you personally will look
at it oh yeah you look at it now you can
do better you do think some stuff oh wow
it's as racist now or it seems that way
but it's also like we've just created
this environment where we can't talk
where somebody can't make a mistake but
then at the same time we're telling
people oh you can make all the mistakes
you want yeah all right you know what
I'm saying like it's okay to make
mistakes you're gonna be fine but we're
not saying in that same argument now 30
years nailed it again yeah you're right
just sick of all of those types of
people and it's usually it's the news
that does this [ __ ] it's not us as
people you know and I find that those
two types of people in the world is
people that blame others and there's
people that just keep moving forward and
put responsibility on their own once you
find you start blaming people other
people for the problems in your life oh
dude yeah if you you end up a lot of the
tracks it's like when a comic or whoever
gets upset because another comic got a
special on netflix or showtime or HBO
I'm like do you think that has anything
to do with you right you what do you
think there's there's only three spots
for show two for specials and you think
because
they got one you're not getting one yeah
you think because your material sucks do
you think because something you're doing
it's not connecting with them yeah or do
you think it's it has nothing to do if
Theo gets it if crystalline of Brogan
that has nothing to do with you right I
see it all the time people get jealous
or upset or [ __ ] on these other guys who
are successful I'm like I don't get it
man yeah that's why you're not them
right right yeah you just got to stay
focused on your own stuff and it's hard
not to especially these days when
everybody else's stuff is so presented
in front of us all the time to social
media yeah used to be it's like I wasn't
worried about so I never thought about
this stuff because I wouldn't see it
constantly you know no social media but
also if you think social media is real
that's three seconds as a person don't
know people need post their success yeah
not posting like [ __ ] man at a showcase
for Showtime a tree on Netflix yeah
eyeball I got this job Wow bruh yeah I
got this via these anal warts no I can't
get rid of him no one's posting that on
that made of boy Doug got these herpes
why would he got you Herbies this this
is going on everywhere The Weather
Channel guy oh yeah so he was kind of
like oh yeah last year sorry this is
what I'm talking about this the news
brah here's your boy Don Lehman's out
here bro Don lemons Brower lon diamond
that's what I call him the lawn demon on
Lehman is a frickin muppet bro Don
lemons whatever that guy's a I mean he
probably painted himself white
completely and put himself in this video
Mulan dude is this news guy look at
those two brothers man calmly look how
he look the best part is when he's on
the grass trying to move his feet around
like it's hard to move that's all there
he's not even like there's any good
actor I mean but of course they're doing
that I assume these boys are doing that
you know I'm saying I don't turn on the
news and take it forward who does know
that's the thing hopefully no one yeah
and then like if you have kids I have a
son you educate him I like that [ __ ]
ain't that's not yeah this all who
belong this isn't real oh dude I
wouldn't even yeah I mean it's almost
better to raise your kid in a cage
probably at the house yeah you're gonna
let him get out in
- Graham yeah and just let somebody else
teach him that you don't even know
really that well that's crazy bro what
does your chin
I just here's what the weather channel
defending him saying it's important to
note the two individuals in the
background are walking on concrete and
my excited I was trying to maintain his
footing on wet grass after reporting on
air until 1:00 a.m. yeah that's what's
wrong with the news like how great would
it be if we came out like yeah listen
he's just trying to get viral
he's just exaggerating we [ __ ] up it's
hilarious though he's just trying to
cover and be entertaining for you guys
doing that like trying to make it like
oh he's on grass look slippery like
everyone's like god damnit man this is
your problem yeah I mean really view
anymore I don't believe any of this junk
man what else got you that's pretty much
it Washington Post Oh bad news from
there always to be reliable Washington
Post no Denver Post son none of these
mug dude I get my room I'll get my new
easy a lizard son instinct rumor it's
legitimate hearsay and [ __ ] that I see
and know it and know with my heart bro
truth I'm saying I'm 119th Cherokee bruh
you know I'm saying I got a dream
catcher and the [ __ ] back on my next
oh yeah son you get your news from the
lot lizards oh no I get my news from you
news bro you just gotta trust your
instinct bro there's a lot of people out
there they don't have any instinct man
right there just Muppets yeah we'll beat
them we will beat them if we trust our
instance a bit baby number that have you
tried to be able not to be pedophiles
baby's gonna give us that classic tune
and I'm not supposed to jack off to it
dude you're not parking the only spot
available outside for leasing for some
showing leasing so I could easily be
towed easily but you're kind of leasing
whatever dude I can only sell this strap
for get a $7 yeah sorry that's that new
Muppet baby a [ __ ] face bro moppy
baby that's a new stuff yeah that's that
chick in the back that ain't real do
they have a show in Vietnam that's like
Muppet Babies or do you know cat just
cuz I'm American right yeah
sorry I should have asked that question
and it's like this no question I think
we should end on that right
how many by feel let's wait about 30
seconds and you'll make one so well
we're ending on that you went OCAD do
you guys have a muppet baby show called
like Muppet lizards and Vietnam like
dude easy bro
dude I would love when I die and I will
say this publicly when I die I'm I'm
ready to come back as an Asian person so
I just want to let you guys know that
and I want to come back as a Russian do
you really yeah big old grizzly resi
problem just move to Russia - dude I'm
not hairy like them all right bro
you have no idea who you are you should
definitely talk to some people and see
who you are
alright dude hi baby Domino's baby if
you want a board game go to Domino's
dude no I mean if you want some [ __ ]
pizza and your Terrace go to Pizza bro
what do you mean if you want to lend
money to your father and then get it
back from them in front of your mother
to pay for pizza you know to pizza go to
Pizza dude if you want to be harassed by
the employees go to Pizza what delicious
quality American Pie go to Domino's or
without your sauce it's a box with pizza
flavoring sprayed in the Apple say this
[ __ ] you Little Caesars oh [ __ ] little
no [ __ ] right there bruh go see Theo
von I'll be in Charlotte in two weeks
and then I will be somewhere else I'm
coming to Buffalo Washington DC it's
already sold out but we're adding a
Sunday show and you can catch me every
Monday and Thursday on this past weekend
this week we have a sex worker that came
in and we have her in she's wearing
disguise because she doesn't want to let
her identity be known but we got that we
got a real sex worker who's working that
you know it's a great show man yeah I'm
into it but uh and Britain's shop will
be coming on to my podcast next week
that's right bro and this Thursday
Friday said I'm Chicago Schomburg improv
following week I'm the parlor live in
Seattle and tickets for you tall just
one on sale get them then Theo and I are
in Phoenix October 27th doing a big show
yeah with big Jay
Ari Shaffir Bryan Callen myself do the
first show sold out so we had a second
show that's almost sold out Phoenix all
things comedy all store all-star Comedy
Festival
yeah Pakistani accom [ __ ] Chris D'Elia
calm that's not a real site bro sadder
but some
it is not a real sight all right this is
this thing in the king we're out